the Spanish painter Francisco Goya is
one of the outstanding artists of the
late 18th and early 19th centuries born
into a middle-class family in 1746 he
began painting young and was quickly
recognized by his contemporaries for his
genius we Acclaim him today for among
other works his masterpieces the 3rd of
May 1808 his portrait of Charles IV and
his family as well as his series of
unflinching prints the disasters of War
however perhaps his most emotionally
compelling work is a print he made in
1799 titled hauntingly and evocatively
the sleep of Reason produces Monsters
the title is Central to the work in case
we were to miss it it's even etched on
the desk and sounds yet more eloquent in
Spanish as Goya knew intimately he'd
been manic depressive since late
adolescence Knight is when things can
become unbearable if our minds are
fragile
what each of goya's monstrous animals
really is is a thought a thought that
can assail us when we're exhausted and
depleted often these nighttime thoughts
are an internalization of the most awful
messages we've ever heard from other
people probably those we grew up around
you're no good you disgust me don't you
dare outsmart me the owl with
outstretched Wings might be shrieking
you'll never achieve anything
furry beaked bat might be hissing your
desires are revolting the links like
thing at the bottom looks on with
judgmentalness I'm so disappointed in
what you've become
during the day when we feel so-called
monsters hovering as we talk to a
colleague or have dinner with friends we
can fend the animals off with rational
arguments of course we've done nothing
wrong there's no reason to keep
apologizing we have the right to exist
but at night we can forget all our
weapons of self-defense why are we still
alive why haven't we given up yet
we don't know what to answer anymore
to survive mentally we might need to
undertake a lengthy analysis of where
each animal came from what it feeds off
what makes it go on the prowl and how it
can be wrestled to submission
one Beast might have been born from our
father's mouth another from our mother's
neglect most of them get excited when we
have too much work when we're exhausted
and when the cities we live in are at
their most frenetic and they hate early
nights nature and the love of friends
we need to learn to manage our monsters
for each one of us has our own version
and we need to do so with all the
respect we owe to something that
potentially has the power to kill us
we need to build very strong cages out
of solid kind arguments against them
at the same time we can take comfort
from the idea that the nighttime
monsters will get less vicious the more
we can lead reasonable Serene lives
with enough gentleness and compassion we
can hope to reach a point when even in
the dead of night as these monsters
chafer their collars and strike at their
bars we will remember enough about
ourselves to be unafraid and to know
that we are safe and worthy of
tenderness
goya's print isn't just an evocation of
night terror it's also pointing us more
hopefully to how we might in time tame
our monsters through love and reason